We lost someone this year,
who was beloved around the world and, especially, here
at Comic-Con and we wanted to do something special
in his memory tonight.
Have a look.
[Narrator] Meanwhile, in the Batcave
(audience cheers and applause)
Hello, Batman speaking.
Some days you just can't get rid of a bomb.
Always inspect a jukebox carefully.
These machines can be deadly.
I knew you'd employ your sneezing powder,
so I took an anti-allergy pill.
Uh oh, better put five cents in the meter.
It's sometimes difficult to think clearly,
when you're strapped to a printing press.
We've come a long way
from the prime minister's exploding cake.
Or have we?
You can't get away from Batman that easy!
Easily.
Good grammar is essential, Robin.
Thank you, Batman.
You're welcome.
Where'd you get a live fish, Batman?
A true crime fighter always carries everything he needs
in his utility belt, Robin.
Gosh, Batman, is there anything you don't know?
Oh, yes, Robin, several things, in fact.
They may be drinkers, Robin, but they're also human beings.
To the Batcave!
Via Batcycle to the Batcopter.
To the Batmobile!
To the Batpoles!
I'll do everything I can to rehabilitate you.
Marry me.
Everything, except that!
(audience cheers and applause)